(slow mellow music)
- [Voiceover] This is the Speke’s gazelle.
The smallest of the gazelle species.
Sadly, it is also one
of the most endangered.
They max out at around
two feet and 40 pounds.
Their biggest feature is their nose
which can puff up to the
size of a tennis ball
when excited.
Native to the Horn of Africa,
they live in semidesert grasslands
and feed on grass, herbs,
shrubs and other plants.
In the 80's,
they were one of the most
abundant gazelle species
in parts of Ethiopia and Somalia,
but today the Ethiopian
population is close to extinction
while numbers in Somalia
have greatly decreased.
A combination of hunting,
drought and overgrazing
has decimated the population.
This is the Speke’s gazelle.
(slow mellow music)